So we're studying nuclear fillic substitution as in part,
at least as a means of seeing how one goes about establishing a mechanism,
proving a mechanism.
Uh,
remember that,
uh,
the sn two nuclear fillic substitution has a number of components here and the
logic is to vary them,
see how the rate changes and see if you can disprove some of the mechanisms.
Uh,
and last time we looked at at,
uh,
at the kinetic order and at stereochemistry and began looking at how the
different components influenced the rate constant.
So here we're looking at,
we looked at the end the last time at the nucleophile and saw that it was gave
unusual it what the reactivity with a carbon in the sn two transition state
didn't seem to parallel the reactivity with the Proton if you want across the
first row it was fine,
but when you went down it looked funny.
But then we saw that the solvent had something to do with it.
That although in water it looks funny,
it's backwards from what you would expect in acetone.
It sensible.
So we concluded that the solvent makes a difference.
This solvent,
hydrogen bonds in a case of water to the nuclear file,
making it less reactive in the smaller,
a more reactive,
the nucleophile,
the,
the more it deactivates it,
the stronger the hydrogen bonding.
And you don't have that factor and acetone,
but that's just one example of a solvent.
In fact,
there's a very general kind of solvent effects where a polar solvent,
uh,
stabilizes ions.
We saw this in the case of water,
the gas phase ions,
how much they were stabilized by having water come around them in the order of a
hundred kilocalories per mole,
uh,
compared to the gas phase.
Okay?
So whenever you generate ions or increase the localization of charge,
you get stronger bonding with polar solvents.
So polar solvents accelerate reactions that generate or concentrate charge
because they bind more strongly to it.
And vice versa.
If charge is being destroyed in the reaction than a polar solvent will stabilize
the starting materials more than it does the transition state and the reaction
will slow down.
So that's an important,
uh,
consideration in choosing a solvent for a reaction.
Now let's look at the leaving group.
Fortunately here things make sense.
Uh,
you notice that,
that the,
uh,
that the stronger the acid that is the more weekly the,
the,
the particular group bonds to a Proton,
the uh,
the,
uh,
the better it is as a leaving group.
That is,
it can give up its bond to carbon.
The same way it gives up its bond to protons.
And there's a strict parallel between how good a nucleophile is and how,
how acidic what it's PKA is.
So weak basis are good leaving groups that is stable and ions form easily or uh,
those that don't hold tightly to h plus don't hold tightly to the carbon in the
transition state of the sn two reaction.
So that makes perfect sense.
Okay,
now we looked last time at the work of Bartlett and knocks this classic work of
using a bridge head reactivity,
this bridge head chloride in order to,
to test some possibilities about about,
uh,
the mechanism of nuclear physics substitution that you can't get at the
backside.
So that's out.
You can't,
uh,
you can't,
form a double bond at the bridge head so you don't have to worry about
elimination and you can't have a non,
the question is whether you could have a non planar cad ion or whether you could
attack from the front instead of from the back.
And by showing that this compound was inert to such substitutions,
they were able to,
uh,
to show that those inferences were correct.
So they specifically designed and prepared this molecule to test these
mechanistic questions.
Incidentally,
since last time I got hold of this,
a picture of Lawrence knocks,
it's his graduation picture from Bates College.
Uh,
now they hit,
he had to prepare the molecule.
How did he prepare it?
Because we're,
what we're saying is it's very difficult to prepare things at the bridge head
because a,
you can't do nuclear affiliate substitution.
That's what their experiment showed.
So how did they do it?
Well,
they started with this mean actually they started with a product that already
had the carboxylate group in there.
Right.
And they converted that to the,
you mean by a reaction we'll discuss later in the semester,
in the last quarter of the semester.
But they had this compound available.
How do they replace Nh two by cl and h two is a crummy leaving group and even a
good grip,
better leaving group like chloride.
Uh,
we,
they,
what they showed was that it doesn't undergo substitution.
So how do you put chloride in,
in place of,
of the Nh two.
You need some fabulous leaving group if you wanted to be able to do something at
the bridge head.
Okay.
So what they did was treat the amine,
uh,
and notice that the amine itself is not a leaving group.
It's the PKA is 34.
So the higher the PKA,
the worst it is as a leaving group as we just saw a,
if you protonated it,
it would make it a much better leaving group because protonated Nh three,
the ammonium ion has a pka that's a whatever,
a 25 powers of 10 better.
But still that's not nearly good enough to make a bridge head cat ion or to do a
substitution.
At the bridge yet.
So what they did was treat the amine with n.
O c l.
Okay.
Now let's think about how those would react with one another.
What makes the Nh two reactive?
Antonio,
what he say?
Yeah,
at the High Homo is
the loan bear on the nitrogen.
So what's it going to attack Antonio?
Keep us going
and,
oh,
okay.
There's a Pi star bond ban,
so it could form a bond to nitrogen.
Uh,
but if you have that negative charge on the oxygen,
that's perfectly good.
And it's almost certainly the way it starts,
but that negative charge can come back in reform on the bond
and lose chloride,
which is a good leaving group.
Okay.
So I'm not going to draw the intermediate step.
That would just probably correct that you suggested,
but just say that it displaces the chloride.
It probably is because of the Pi star that does it so easily.
Although it could do it directly.
Okay.
So then we're going to have chloride displaced and a positive charge on this
nitrogen.
What will happen next?
Well,
how do you get rid of positive charge is on nitrogen like that?
we need here we have an eye on
generally there are other things around that.
We'll take that that are better at having positive charge than this.
Can you think of some way you can get rid of that positive charge?
What did we just say about the protonated nitrogen?
Remember number,
it's PKA is nine.
It's 25 powers of 10 easier.
Better as a leaving group.
Then that is to give up a proton.
Then
Nh three is to give up a proton and form Nh.
Two minus.
It's much better to have an h.
Three is the leaving group try Vaillant nitrogen rather than the an island.
So it's acidic.
It gives up a proton.
Good.
Okay.
Now what would the next thing you need to do to get toward the product?
I mean obviously this particular reaction wasn't figured out on paper by saying
what's the whole ball,
what's the Lumo and saw and they mixed it and found out what happened.
But we can predict what's going to happen.
And,
but fortunately I have some insight into what does happen.
So I know what has to happen next.
What you have to do is have what's called an Al Lilly rearrangement,
where you shift the double bond and the age.
So the h goes from end to,
oh,
the double bond goes between the two ends,
right from one end to the other of a three Adam Alec system.
Okay?
Now how do we go about that?
Well first we can put the Proton and unshared pair of oxygen.
That's pretty easy,
right?
And now there's a resonance structure of that involving the unshared pair on
nitrogen again,
right?
So we can go in and the double bond can put the,
the,
the Pi electrons can go onto oxygen in the resonance structure we're talking
about.
So now we've done the elderly rearrangement,
except it's still got a positive charge on the nitrogen for what do you do now
to get rid of the positive charge on the nitrogen?
Is the Proton again.
Okay,
now you do the same thing again.
Watch this.
So you've protonate protonate the water,
right?
And now use the unshared pair of the nitrogen,
And we're going to draw two arrows,
right?
Right.
So you form a triple bond between the two nitrogens and water is a good leaving
group,
right?
So we have that and now that truly is a fabulous leaving group.
What is the leaving group?
What's going to leave
Roy
and too,
right?
I,
I looked,
I couldn't find a PKA for protonated into,
it just has no affinity for nitrogen for a hydrogen,
for a proton at all.
I can't,
I couldn't find it,
but it's certainly a very,
very strong acid protonated nitrogen gas,
right?
So it's very good leaving group and you get into,
and it as a leaving group can generate even a bridge head cat ion.
The thing that you can't do with chloride,
even with the help of silver ion is Bartlett and Knox found.
Okay?
So once you have that,
remember we already got the chloride from the first reaction.
So he just put that in and that's how they made it,
right?
So there are leaving groups even better than these.
And two is a fabulous leaving group,
right?
And can even make the bridge head Cat Island.
Now this idea of of a protonated or charging things in order that they leave as
neutral molecules like n two is also present in molecules in this,
in the list we already have here like Roi h has.
That's a very bad leaving group O h minus,
right.
However,
if you protonate it then you have water as the leaving group and that's good.
You've changed the,
you've changed the PKA by a 17 and a half powers of 10 you've changed the PK by
a 17 and a half units.
That is the equilibrium constant by that many powers of 10 so that becomes very
good and in fact there is another good way of doing it.
So that's acid Katala PSAs to help lose o h that is you lose it as water not as
o h minus and another way is to convert it into a sulfonate Ester,
which is a good leaving group.
Did you ever see that for sure
to have that complicated thing leave instead of Ooh minus
because of the new dispensation?
Yeah.
That the exam is going to be on Friday rather than Wednesday.
You have a whole week to learn that.
Okay.
So that was what Kenyon and Phillips did remember in order to study the
inversion.
Okay.
So there's,
there's,
there are tricks leaving group tricks and there's lore about that of what you
could do to help make,
Ooh,
a leaving group.
You can protonate it had to have the leaving group B,
h two o.
So that can be the leaving group O h two plus.
And then it leaves as h two O.
Right.
So we can look at an example of that.
So here's bromide going to displace hydroxide.
So we can imagine that,
uh,
coming on and hydroxide going off.
But there's a problem with this.
The PKA of of water is 16 roughly,
right?
And the PK of HBR is minus five.
So one way to say it is that bromide is a much better,
and I on that hydroxide is right at one one,
one of them is going to be protonated.
Okay.
What does that mean about this reaction that you'd rather have bromide than have
hydroxide?
Luke,
what does that say about this reaction to make a lot of money doing that
reaction?
Why not?
I can't even remember.
That probably wouldn't happen.
What would happen?
You go the other direction.
All right?
So would go that way.
Okay.
And I see it start with an expensive starting material and make a cheap product
if you wanted to use that reaction.
But if you put HBR in there,
you protonate it,
right?
Because HBR has a pka of five,
but,
but water or alcohol has a,
has a pka of of minus 1.7.
So there's a difference between that of,
uh,
of uh,
over three.
So it's more than a thousand times better to protonate the oxygen than it is to
protonate br minus.
So this reaction,
we'll certainly go in the right direction,
right?
And now you have a great leaving group.
Okay?
So bromide is a good nucleophile and we'll displace water.
So without,
without,
if you just tried using sodium,
sodium bromide as the source of bromide,
it wouldn't work.
But if you use hydro,
bro,
make acid,
then you zip up the starting material and now it's downhill to the product.
Okay.
And you can cleave ethers.
You know ether is a very common solvent.
I suspect you've used an ether in lab,
right?
Because it doesn't react well with new what you can do have lots of nuclear
files in there,
but you don't displace or minus.
You don't,
that's not alleving group,
that's not a good leaving group.
It's like oh h minus.
Right?
But if you use HBR like this example here,
excess 47% HBR treated for eight hours,
it protonate and now you have a good leaving group.
So you have a good nucleophile and a good leaving group.
The bromide can attack the carbon and the alcohol is the leaving group is the
okay.
And then we already saw that the alcohol reacts with Hbr to give a bromide.
So you convert the ether completely to the bromide if you add HBR.
So HBR can cleave ethers.
Okay.
So that's one trick to make h minus into a leaving group to make Ooh into o h
two plus.
Okay.
Another one is the one we already alluded to and talked about last time,
which is to convert the alcohol into a what's called a sulfonate Esther Atossa
late.
The reason it's called tarsal aid is that that acid is called Tal Uie and soul
phonic acid.
So it's abbreviated Tasi tosic acid.
So Tasi late is the,
uh,
is the leaving group and that the PK of that acid is minus three.
So it's not surprising.
It's a good leaving group and worked well for Kenyon and Phillips in 1923.
That's a very common way to make alcohols into leaving groups.
Another way is talked about in,
in the Jones text,
which is uh oh s OCL.
Okay.
So the way to get that is to start,
as they say here with thigh and Neil Chloride SOCL too,
which reacts with the alcohol to give an alcohol chloride plus s o two and hcl.
And there's an example shown here of a particular acid being converted with
financial chloride,
chloroform,
a hundred degrees,
two hours into an 80% yield.
They say of this plus s o two and hcl 80% is not such a great yield for this
reaction.
I've done this.
This is one of the reactions I've done a lot and it really gives very,
very good yields.
Typically,
one of the reasons it's so handy is that the byproducts are gases.
So you don't have to do any separation.
They just go away.
You can appreciate from lab how handy it would be if you didn't have to do any
purification of the product at the end.
Everything just went up the hood.
Okay.
And furthermore,
uh,
there's,
there seems to be a little bit of a problem here because they said they did this
in chloroform at a hundred degrees.
It could be that the bath was at a hundred degrees,
but if so,
the solution wasn't at a hundred degrees.
Does anybody have an idea why that might be?
Cause the boiling point of chloroform is 61 and the boiling point of vinyl
chloride is 75 so it'd be very difficult to get a solution like that he did to a
hundred degrees.
Right.
So the reason I put point this out on this,
uh,
page from the book is that,
Professor Jones is a great friend of mine and a very good physical organic
chemist and he has,
he's taken the prob the,
uh,
care and his book as in most good books to actually put in real examples,
not just theoretical examples made up out of your head.
You know,
there was a,
there was a very famous professor in the,
uh,
in the first half of the 20th century at Mit whose occupation in the summer was
to write textbooks.
But he did it by going up to his cabin in Maine and writing the textbooks there
where he had no access to a library.
So everything he wrote,
he made up out of his head in there.
Right.
Much better to have an example like this where they give exactly what the yield
is 80% and what the conditions were.
But even in this case,
I doubt that that really was the condition,
although that might've been what the,
what the heating mantle was at 100 degrees with the solution,
couldn't possibly have been at 100 degrees.
Even though when you mix things,
the boiling point is elevated,
but it wouldn't be that much elevated I don't think.
But the reason I mentioned that is not just the to,
uh,
point out that you have to take things with a grain of salt and look as much as
you can and original literature if you really want to repeat some,
uh,
process.
Uh,
but to point out that that final deal,
chloride is a rather,
is not a very high boiling liquid.
So in fact,
all you do is take the alcohol.
You don't need a chloroform at least I'd never used a solvent.
This is a liquid.
This'll dissolve this,
right?
And as,
and the product chloride is the liquid even in,
uh,
with bigger molecules where the alcohol might be a solid.
So you just heat it up and for awhile reflux it and then distill out.
And this SOCL to still distills out the two and HCL distills out.
And all you're left with is the,
is the,
uh,
Al Kill chloride.
It's a beautiful reaction.
Okay.
And here's an example.
An example there that shows the mechanism of this.
The crucial part is this.
You,
the,
the alcohol display displaces that sulfur.
So the chloride goes away and you get our,
oh,
and this is the new bond.
So cl right now,
uh,
pardon me,
I said the wrong thing.
At first you'd display,
yeah,
you displaced one of these chlorides with the,
Oh,
so you get R,
O,
s,
l.
But now the neat reaction is that you generated chloride in that process when
you eliminated a chloride here,
that chloride can do an sn two displacement on the are these electrons go in
here.
But at the same time,
these chloride,
these electrons go onto the chloride.
So you directly make [inaudible] two and cl.
So it's an unusual kind of leaving,
leaving group cause it breaks apart as it leaves
day.
Now another way,
uh,
to,
to make the Oah into alleving group is to have it be,
uh,
have phosphorous on there with electron withdrawing groups on it.
Because as it turns out,
the double bond between phosphorus and oxygen is quite a strong one.
Remember that phosphorus has d orbitals that are vacant so they can stabilize a
electrons on the adjacent oxygen or when you make a negative charge there.
Okay?
And if x is something that's electro negative,
this is a very good leaving group.
So here's an example of an alcohol tweeted with PBR three and it gives a 58%
yield.
They sat here with specific conditions,
ad and a phosphoric acid as a byproduct.
Okay?
And here's another example.
Uh,
we using PCL five,
right?
It says 100%,
but aware of things that say the yield is 100%.
That's a sign that the person probably wasn't very careful.
Have you ever gotten a 100% yield in lab?
These people may be,
have more experience than you,
but they're not that much better.
Very rarely do you truly get 100% yield.
Okay.
Uh,
now,
how does this work?
Well,
first you do a substitution that phosphorous,
so the o of the Oah attacks phosphorous and displaces chloride,
probably that's a d a association and dissociation probably you first form a
bond to phosphorous.
Remember it as vacant d orbitals and then the chloride leaves.
Okay?
So you have this with these electronegative groups on it and now that can be a
good leaving group,
right?
So you've converted o h into this good leaving group.
Now that's an interesting,
why is that particular one of interest in context of what we've been talking
about lately?
What's interesting about that particular argument to do it as a substitution of
that carbon,
Linda,
okay,
I can do real
Aha.
Can't do a backside attacks,
right?
This is like the Bartlett knocks thing,
It's set up so you can't get a nucleophile to the backside.
The alternative remember was to,
uh,
have it leave and leave a cad ion,
right?
Just leave without the help from being back side.
Uh,
but,
uh,
what we learned from this,
the fact that we get a 100% yield is that we can do that.
So these rings are bigger.
Remember the one that Bartlett and Knox made,
the bridges were two carbons,
two carbons and one carbon.
Here are the rings are much bigger,
so it's easier to distort the angles in order to flatten the rings.
Okay?
So you can do substitution.
That bridge had cad ions,
just not when the rings are involving bridge had cat and it's just not when the
rings are very small.
But what you learn here is that this,
uh,
this leaving group is good enough to do that even though it's a bridge head.
Okay?
Another trick is this one called the apple reaction.
I took this figure from Wikipedia.
Uh,
the reagents that you add to the alcohol are,
uh,
try fennel phosphene and carbon tetrachloride and unusual reagent.
You more often would think of that as a solvent then as a reagent.
But as you see,
what happens is the unshared pair on phosphorus does a substitution on carbon
tetrachloride,
but the phosphorus attacks chloride,
not carbon.
So it attacks the chloride and CCL three minus is the leaving group because the
three chlorines are sufficiently electron attractive that the,
that the anti and is not a bad anti.
And it's the PKA of chloroform is 24.
So it's pretty easy to generate that and I,
and,
and lose a proton.
Now notice that this stage,
when you add the alcohol,
it's PK is about 17.
So the try chloro methyl and ion,
although it's unusually stable for a carbon and iron is much,
uh,
more avid to get a proton than the,
than the Oh of the,
uh,
of the alcohol is.
So it takes,
so this base that you'd made made in the first reaction,
the leaving group takes the proton off the alcohol.
And now you have orr minus.
But now you have,
uh,
the,
the possibility for chloride to attack this carbon where you've made this new
bond here.
That's probably an association followed by dissociation.
But notice the substitution is that phosphorus,
uh,
because the o attack,
the phosphorus and chloride came off.
So here's the chloride.
It does a nuclear filex substitution.
Now at carbon and fennel three Po try fennel.
Phosphine oxide is the leaving group.
And that's a super leaving group.
This is a very strong bond.
The Po,
a double bond there.
So this converted,
Ooh,
f what would have been an Oah leaving group into this try fennel,
phosphene cad I and which leaves to get make,
try funnel phosphine oxide.
Uh,
so you've made a very good leaving group out of an oxygen.
So what this shows is that there are lots of ways to skin a cat.
You know,
O h minus is a terrible leaving group,
but we have lots of different ways of going at it.
You can,
you can protonate it,
you can,
uh,
you can use SOCL to,
you can,
uh,
use the phosphorus,
a chloride or bromides the phosphorus highlights.
And you can do this funny trick and the apple reaction using,
try funnel phosphene and carbon tetrachloride.
And here's an example from the book.
So the Oah was from the,
uh,
from the Jones' book where the o h,
is made into a leaving group by try fennel phosphene and carbon tetrachloride.
It says it was done over a day at room temperature.
And here's the chloride notice it inverted the presence of deuterium comes here,
allows you to know whether,
whether the,
the,
uh,
configuration is,
is retained or inverted.
And as you expect with an sn two reaction,
it's inverted.
Now.
Uh,
so we've,
we've looked a lot at these,
uh,
these,
that this mechanism.
Let's see how you can use knowledge of the mechanism to do something useful.
In this particular case,
it was to maximize synthetic speed in order to do,
to,
uh,
to uh,
make pet scanning possible.
Do people know what pet scanning is?
Pet what the P stands for?
The P is positron.
And what is a positron?
It's something you don't encounter very often.
You can't buy a bottle of it.
Pardon me?
It's anti matter.
It's an
positive electron.
It's an electron that has a positive charge instead of a negative charge.
So that's a positron.
Now,
where do you get positrons?
You get 'em by nuclear,
you're
decay,
unstable isotopes,
decay to give a number of particles.
But one that's given,
especially in the case of,
uh,
of f 18 is,
is uh,
uh,
cause so f 18 can give off.
You can have one of its protons in the nucleus become a new tron.
That is,
it's the same,
it's the same particle,
but it loses a positive charge,
right?
So Proton becomes a neutron.
So instead of fluoride,
it's now oxygen,
right?
So you've made a new element,
And it's lost a positive charge.
So,
so if it was f minus its oxygen,
double minus,
but it's the same mass,
right?
18 because all you lost was this positive electron.
Now when you have a positive electron,
it goes away instantly because the anti matter meets its corresponding matter
and electron,
right where it lives,
right?
It's there,
it's made right there.
But there are a zillion electrons around.
Even on the same atom,
there are like trons.
So when the two,
when the electron and a positron meet one another,
they annihilate,
they go away.
And what comes out is two photons gamma particles,
which is you saw flew off anti parallel to one another along the same line.
So you get,
if you have a detector,
you see a fly ash here and detected over there as well.
Now you can do that again and again.
You can get Bingo those to happen at the same time,
right?
Because they came from the same decay or those two.
Right?
So if you surround the thing with the detector that can tell when things hit it
when two things hit it at the same time,
right?
They came from the same nuclear decay.
Okay.
Now do you see what you could do with respect to imaging?
Yeah.
How could you tell where the sample that had flury and was that had fluorine 18
all you know is where are these things hit your detector?
You see what you do to figure out where they came from?
Aha.
Yes.
You trace lines.
So if you connect those,
where they intersect is where the fluorine 18 was.
Each line comes from one fluorine 18 but the sample had a number of fluorine,
18 senate.
So they they,
so you find out where the sample was.
Okay.
Now,
uh,
if you want to use this imaging defined tumors,
you have to find some way to get flurry in 18 to where the tumor is.
And then if you put the,
surround the patient with this detector and measure these simultaneous flashes
or detection events,
then you know where that substance was.
So if you could make that substance be in the tumor,
then you're home free,
but you have to do it.
You can read about it then as I did in Wikipedia.
Uh,
what you have to do this,
you have to do this really quickly after you've prepared the element,
right?
So you prepare the element f 18,
but it's half life is only a 110 minutes,
so you don't have much time to make it into something that will go where the or
is.
So speed is of the essence and doing whatever kind of synthesis you're going to
get.
Now where do you get f 18 you get it from all eight t in the same as the product
by adding a proton and losing a new tron.
Okay,
so you don't change the bass,
right?
But you,
but you put a positive charge in to the nucleus so you,
so you get flury in instead of oxygen,
okay?
Now,
okay,
fine.
If you have all 18 you buy oh 18,
uh,
then your butt,
your,
but where are you going to get a proton that's going really fast?
7 million electron volts.
You have to get it from an accelerator right from a cyclotron,
okay?
Now you can also do it with carb making in place of Fluor and you could have
carbon or nitrogen or oxygen,
but they have even shorter half life.
So you have to work even quicker in order to have any there at the time to get
it where you want it to be detected.
Now if you go onto the pet center.yale.edu you see that they do this positron
emission tomography,
and you see what they have as a cyclotron that generates these high energy
protons that can convert one element into one of these radioactive elements
that'll generate positrons,
okay?
And you see they have a water target so that you can produce fluoride.
They also have targets to produce those other elements I talked about.
And they say they also have two fluorine,
18 synthesis modules,
one for nuclear,
Felix substitution and one for electrophilic substitution.
Okay.
So,
but the question is,
so they have,
they have the facility for making this stuff and then doing reactions quickly
with it.
Right?
But the question is what are you going to sit the size so that it will go to a
tumor so you can find where the tumor is and you have to do it really quickly,
right?
Well,
glucose is the basis of metabolism and tubers are growing rapidly,
so they really snarfy up,
uh,
glucose.
Okay.
So if you had f 18 and glucose,
uh,
that might do the trick,
right?
If you could make two flouro glucose,
right,
with an f 18 in it,
maybe that would suck up a,
it be sucked up by the tumors the same way that glucose is.
So we need to make that molecule as quickly as possible from glucose.
Okay.
Well,
let's just do as a nuclear Philly's substitution,
Fluor idea in hydroxide out.
Does that sound good?
Or might there be problems with that in doing the sn two reaction?
Did you think of a problem doing this reaction?
Fluoride comes in and displaces Oah to give the compound on the right,
which has the same shape as glucose.
Lauren,
what's up buddy?
Problem.
Okay,
so the hydroxides a crummy leaving group.
Whoops.
And it didn't,
it was supposed to come up there,
but it didn't.
I had anticipated you,
but uh,
I think I did.
Let's see what the next one is.
Yeah,
but it could be that the wrong CEO to the wrong carbon gets attacked.
There are lots of ohs here.
Even if it could be attacked that the others could be just as good.
And if you did sn two a displacement at the oxygen,
even if you attack that one,
it would give the wrong Fluor 18
arrangement.
Oh,
there's Lauren's,
right?
It's a terrible leaving group.
Okay.
That's not all.
That's possible.
That's wrong with this.
A fluoride is a horrid nucleophile as we saw right member at a it,
it's tied up by hydrogen bonding.
So you have to break the hydrogen bonds and it's very small and highly charged.
So it's has very strong hydrogen bonds.
And furthermore,
uh,
it's tied up by the potassium cad ion,
right?
Which makes it less reactive.
So you've got lots and lots of problems.
So that doesn't look like it's going to do the trick.
All right,
now,
can we address these problems on the basis of what we've been talking about?
Can we figure out some way of doing it so we can do this transformation really
rapidly after the cyclotron generates this stuff?
That's half of it's going away every couple hours.
Okay.
How bout the sn two inversion version gives the wrong configuration.
What could we do to get the right configuration if we did an inversion
use a different starting material.
Right?
And it turns out that mannose,
which has this,
Ooh,
axial pointed up,
is readily available.
It's a different sugar.
And if you did substitution on that,
you'd get the equatorial thing that you wanted.
That would be so that's no problem.
Now we have the problem that the wrong CEO could be attacked.
There are,
there are uh,
uh,
there are,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five different Coh is in here.
So what you have to do is make one of them different from the others,
right?
The one you want to attack has to be different from the others.
And the way you do it is has been known a long time in sugar chemistry,
which is you can protect some of the groups and not another one.
So what w what's done here is to,
is to put assets,
deal groups on all the other four but not on this particular h and how that's
done,
we won't go into,
now that's a topic and sugar chemistry,
but you know how to do it.
Okay.
Now,
but there's a problem here that still,
that o h minus is a horrid leaving group.
It's now different from the others,
but it's a horrid leaving group and Acetate is a better leaving group,
right?
It's,
it's a more acidic compound,
a CT Cason than water better.
And I,
okay.
So what are we going to do now,
Lauren?
It was your,
this was your problem.
That the,
Ooh,
my one.
They leaving move.
What did we do?
Try to from here to here,
try to protonate it.
We could,
we could,
we could probably get it,
but you're good.
Protonate the acetates to would make them better leaving groups so that won't do
the trick.
Okay.
What they did was converted into a sole phonic acid.
Now the one that Kenyon and Phillips did had a fennel group here,
or a Tall Youin,
actually a benzene with a methyl on the edge of it.
This is CF three white.
My CF three be better than just a regular old hydrocarbon like tall youin.
It's got the flu or Ian's in it that are electron withdrawing.
So it makes this,
it makes the anti and you're gonna want to leave.
Leave this o s o two CF three is a much stronger acid.
Right.
But much more stable and I,
and a better leaving group.
Uh,
so that's great.
It's the PKA of the corresponding acid here is minus 14.
It's called a super acid.
Remember the the strongest when we've talked about so far had a PK of minus 11.
This is a thousand times stronger than Hii.
So it's a great,
so we put on are really super leaving group.
It's called,
it's trifluridine methane sulfonate and called flight.
Okay.
So now we have a compound that's as good as we can make it for being attacked,
uh,
at this center,
not the others,
uh,
for having a great leaving group and for having the proper stereochemistry,
right?
So that will get the fluoride where we want it.
And now we have to do the reaction with fluoride,
right?
Notice that all of this can be done ahead of time.
We can have the bottom right,
a molecule take however much time we want to make it.
Now we have it in a bottle.
We go to the cyclotron at the medical school,
get fluoride,
18 right?
And try to do our substitution.
Right now we have to introduce the flouride 18,
right?
So we want to have to go from this protected,
trifling late.
To this compound as soon as we can,
right?
Because it's the fluorides giving off these positrons all the time.
Okay.
So we,
so let's react it with potassium fluoride with fluoride.
18.
Okay.
What's the problem?
The fluoride is tied up by hydrogen bonding.
It's not a good nucleophile.
How could we,
how could we get around that problem of the hydrogen bonding,
deactivating fluoride?
Any ideas on that one?
How can Lauren,
could you shoot a solid change the salt,
something
that can't make bonds,
right?
So they use,
uh,
a cdot night trial,
methyl cyanide,
which doesn't have any,
uh,
hydrogen bonding protons in it.
It has cah protons,
but those aren't involved in hydrogen bonding.
So that's no problem.
But we still have this last problem that potassium cad ion is going to be
tightly associated with the fluoride and we're going to have to break it away to
make the fluoride more reactive.
How can we make the,
how can we get rid of the potassium cad?
I am.
Do you remember the problem is the potassium,
a single atom is rather small.
If it were big,
then it wouldn't attract by Coolamons law,
the fluoride so tightly,
then you wouldn't have to worry about it.
How could we make potassium big?
Harvard.
Did you have an idea?
Dolan?
Don't they don't like I always get bigger if you add an electron,
uh,
well if you add an electron to the potassium cat,
I,
and it's not a cat I anymore,
it's not the thing that's associated.
So it has to still be a cad ion,
but you want to make it bigger.
How do you make a potassium cad?
I am big.
Ah,
but that's,
uh,
that's,
that's an interesting idea,
but I don't think it's practical because you couldn't have enough light to,
to,
uh,
to make a significant number of them bigger all at the same time without just
blowing everything apart.
Okay.
Hey,
Matt,
could you separate it?
You see a crowney through [inaudible] or even better?
It's a crip date.
Okay.
So you make it big that way.
And now the fluoride's a good nucleophile.
There's no hydrogen bonding.
The cad ion is really big.
Okay.
And now you can do that.
So that's how they do it.
Okay,
so it's all this using these ideas to figure out how to tune the sn two reaction
to make it as efficient as possible.
And of course there's one more step you have to then take off these acetate
groups,
but you can do that just by treating it with water and acid.
Okay.
And here's an example of a of a pet scan image that's measured one hour after
administering.
So you have,
you have not only have to make the stuff,
you have to give it to the patient and the patient has to process it enough that
that compound gets to where the tumor is.
Now it goes to where glucose is being consumed,
the two flouro glucose and one place that a lot of glucose is being consumed is
up there.
Where's that?
Is it happening for you?
If I had given you a do flouro glucose and was looking at your boss,
the prawns,
when I see them coming from here,
all right.
That's where a lot of metabolism,
but unfortunately
also there.
And if we slice through there and tip it up,
you can see that that's the,
uh,
that's the tumor that was located this way.
Uh,
so the metabolism was in the brain but also in a cancerous lymph node.
Okay.
So understanding how nuclear filex substitution works,
how to control it was crucial in designing this technique.
Okay.
Now one last topic which I'll just introduce here and then we'll uh,
we'll complete next time.
Is the,
we've talked about stereochemistry late rate law and rate constant,
but can you do actual structural work?
Remember how we talked about the mechanism of,
of a nucleophile attacking the carbon yield group.
And you could do it by x Ray.
You could get a bunch of different compounds that had nitrogens in different
positions relative to the carbon eel and you could put them together and sort of
a movie in the Borghi done.
It's a material that we did last semester and see the stage of the reaction.
Might you be able to do that for a nuclear fillic substitution?
Might you be able to use x-ray and if not extra,
at least use quantum mechanics to see what the structure of this intermediate
is.
Because what's hard to tell we,
so far we've mostly been beating up on the dissociation and association back in
is most of the things we've disproven are things that involve that mechanism
with the Tri Vaillant carbon intermediate,
although it can happen and we're going to talk about it next day that go through
the intermediate cad I am right.
So there are some cases where it would flow applies,
but the tougher problem is to distinguish between concerted and association
dissociation with a very weakly stabilized pentavalent intermediate.
Uh,
so there's some stuff on the course website about that,
but the question is might there be a pentavalent intermediate instead of the
concerted transition state?
So here's the transition state,
which is an energy maximum and here's the pentavalent intermediate.
So there would be nothing to see at the transition state here.
It wouldn't last any time is just passing through.
But if there were a little dimple up at the top,
there could be some stability.
That is,
that is a stable pentavalent carbon.
Uh,
but does it exist?
You can see that if it got,
it would merge smoothly into the one if it just had a teeny tiny dimple or a
little bit bigger dibble.
If we're big enough,
you might be able to prepare it under some circumstances where you could
actually see it say an x ray.
Right?
But if it's too small,
you're never going to see it.
You might be able to try to calculate it by quantum mechanics.
So the question is,
is there an example of a pentavalent carbon?
So by quantum mechanics they said that that for water displacing a h two o,
so that cad ion that,
that,
uh,
symmetrical compound there is actually a transition state,
not an intermediate.
It goes downhill if you,
if you distort linkedin,
one bond and short than the other.
And the same is true in the anti and if these are of course calculations of
isolated materials.
So gas phase,
if you have OAH minus come in and displace,
Ooh,
minus that one.
Quantum mechanics also says is a transition state,
but neither reaction is practical in the laboratory.
So the question is,
what does experiments say?
Can you do X-ray's studies and actually see whether there might be a stable
pentavalent may be very transiently stable,
very weakly stabilized,
but might that pentavalent compound be stable?
So that's what we'll talk about the x-ray material next time.